wo ist das eklig also dass immer direkt
das kann ich nicht weiter ist man muss
kurz um etwas geht ab und herzlich
willkommen bei einem neuen video
ich hoffe natürlich geht es gut leute
heute habe ich mal wieder was ganz
anderes vor
was ihr eigentlich so gar nicht von mir
gewohnt zeigt aber ich hätte da einfach
mal bock drauf weil hier auf märkte in
letzter zeit es gibt immer mehr sachen
die mit essen zu tun haben okay das ist
jetzt legen wir auch nichts neues aber
vor allem die besten videos sich auch
viele messen gedreht und ich habe immer
so eine challenge gesetzt ich habe ihnen
mathe sehen da hat jemand versucht also
das war jetzt nicht in deutschland oder
so da hat jemand versucht ein ganzes
menü für einen dollar zu kochen also
bald losgehen im supermarkt sachen
einkaufen um dann zu schauen mit wie
wenig geld man halt sag ich mal satt
wird und ich fand es ganz interessant
deswegen habe ich gedacht wir probieren
das heute mal aus ich bin also erst mal
nachdenken für unter 1 euro ist hier
schon krass weil allein irgendwie nudel
kosten ja schon meistens 60 70 sensor
eine packung ich habe mir aber die sind
ein neues budgetgesetz wir schauen mal
wie viel es dann am ende wirklich ist
und damit halb ein ganzes menü zu kochen
sagt unter mir nie verstehe ich jetzt
ein getränk dann einen hauptgang und
nachspeise eventuell und ob das klappt
das schauen wir heute mal ich muss
direkt am anfang noch sagen ich bin kein
besonders guter koch eigentlich würde
ich sogar sagen ich kann fast gar nicht
kochen
doch das sagt jetzt einfach so und
deswegen den zwar nicht übel wenn ich
irgendwas falsch macht oder so ihr könnt
mich gerne in den kommentaren verbessern
aber das macht das ganze jahr witzig und
unterhaltsam und mal schauen ob sondern
schmeckt oder halt nicht ich bin
gespannt wie geld erst mal einkaufen bis
gleich so leute ich war jetzt erstmal
zum aldi aber erstmal muss ich noch
also ich habe das ganze irgendwie in
amerika gesehen da hat man sich
konzentrieren um hierdurch zu kommen da
dazu ein typ für 1 dollar mit ganz wenig
gekocht man muss auch sagen die haben in
amerika irgendwie so supermärkte da gibt
es mehr günstige sachen wir fahren jetzt
hier mal zu aldi und ich hoffe da gibt
es auch bei der sache weil all dieser
gedanke dass man so schwierig eine
kamera zu halten und sich danach aufs
autofahren zu konzentrieren und dann
auch noch von einer hand was ja
eigentlich abschluss gefährlich ist aber
ich muss sagen ich rufe die ganze zeit
auf die straße
und wenn ich so am handy und abgelenkt
also kamera halten etwas anderes als
auch handy kunden auf jeden fall ist
aldi das günstigste in deutschland habe
ich auch meistens irgendwann mal
getestet deswegen kommen wir da jetzt
hin und schauen vielleicht glaubt dass
hier wirklich so angekommen bei aldi ob
das klappt heute haben wir schon mal so
nudeln 39 cent also ich bin jetzt schon
wieder draußen und ich muss ganz ehrlich
sagen irgendwie gar nichts außer diesen
nudeln mit dem westen nicht zufrieden
das war mir alles irgendwie zu teuer und
wir reden ja hier von einem ganzen mini
also mit nachtisch ja da wäre ich auf
jeden fall über einem euro gelandet
deswegen fahre jetzt weiter zu liebe
glaube ich mal schauen ich hoffe es
klappt und ist an eine lecker dass mein
ziel nämlich wir werden sehen so leute
ich war schon bei lidl hat mir diese sah
nie so holt hat 49 cent gekostet ich
habe jetzt eigentlich noch zwölf cent
übrig dann folgen das hab ich gedacht
hey dieser trinkjoghurt kostet nur 25
cent ist voll runtergesetzt dir nimmst
du mit vielleicht kann man daraus
natürlich machen habe ich jetzt gekauft
hat irgendwie euro 20 gekostet darum
habe ich mich anscheinend verguckt
deswegen suche ich jetzt noch so ein
naturjoghurt oder so für nachtisch weil
da habe ich eine idee wie man das
eventuell mit dieser sache die ich auch
für die nudeln benutzen würde und ja ich
kann absolut nicht kochen habe ich ja am
anfang schon gesagt kombinieren könnte
und trotzdem was eventuell leckeres
rauszubringen
ich nehme hier einfach mal das
obwohl das bisschen wenig also ich habe
mich jetzt tatsächlich für dieses
zitronen dinge entschieden keine anrufe
damit irgendwas anstellen können ich
habe jetzt mal so stark gewürzte wie wir
sie haben nicht dazu gezählt ich halt
auch eventuelle verwenden werde
weil sonst ist das einfach nicht möglich
allein so ein pfeffer hier kostet ja
schon zwei euro oder so ihr habt ja
schon gesehen ich habe folgende sachen
gekauft mit mir einmal die nudeln für 39
cent also es muss ihnen was mir anders
geht's nicht alle anderen selbst viel zu
teuer
kann sein dass mich jetzt die erste
schon auslachen aber ich habe hier saure
sahne gekauft die brauche ich auch für
die nudeln einfach aus dem grund die hat
halt zehn prozent fett flüssige sahne
die wäre schon viel zu teuer gewesen
sagen habe ich die immer und dann hier
für den nachtisch zitronen bewusst dass
ich gerne dann haltet euch fest mit so
einem stück schokolade was ich noch im
kühlschrank hat menschenwürde und dann
eventuell noch den rest von dieser seite
dazu dass man halt so eine art zitronen
schokoladencreme hat und dann 100 zu
schauen ob das schmeckt oder nicht mein
mitbewohner bzw der kameramann trödel
schon den kopf kann ich auch verstehen
aber ja darum geht heute das menü soll
das hat nicht unter 1 euro kostet
insgesamt hat ist ein euro gekostet
günstiger ging ich jetzt habe ich schon
genug erzählt wir fangen wir an zu
kochen okay leute letzter dieser deckel
passt man dann dort richtig dass wir
haben einen wert von 40.000 drin kommen
egal
das war wirklich so die billigsten ohne
lima sich nur vorstellen kann
39 cent will mal gespannt ob die autos
stecken so dass wir sagen kochen jedoch
nicht wir haben 500 gramm nudeln ich
solle einfach mal 150 rein mehr raum
nicht nachts habe ich schon rein gemacht
war glaube ich nicht auch sandra da wir
können jetzt auch mal gucken hier bitte
würde 23 also ich bin wirklich mal so
gespannt wie das wird klar so ein
getränk habe ich konnte ich ja nicht
kaufen die sind ja viel zu teuer
deswegen habe ich mir gedacht wir nehmen
einfach leitungswasser und kann man hier
wir können noch so eine sonder
multivitamin tablette rheinbacher dann
haben wir praktischen multivitamin
getränk ist wieder komplett
aber vielleicht schmeckt guck mal was
passiert selbst bei meinen eltern
manchmal also ist hier schon mal
passiert deswegen sollten wir das nicht
übel und ich wollte auch gucken ob es
nicht irgendwie noch so abgelaufene
lebensmittel gibt da gibt es eigentlich
manchmal diese abteilung aber ich habe
nichts gefunden ich war ja erst beim
aldi lidl dann noch bei hit also bei
drei supermärkte für drei verschiedene
sachen ja ich glaube sowieso hinfällig
sein merkmal gabe newell ist soweit
fertig und jetzt frage ich mich mal die
soße kannst du mir das sagen wie das ist
muss man erst je sahen rhein und oder
besser danach erst die nudel in die
pfanne
weil ich hatte halt vor sondern
entspannte soße zu machen hat mit der
sahne
dann haben wir hier noch so ein bisschen
pfeffer bisschen curry das ist auch mal
lecker weil ich feiere rudel mit curry
richtig und so ein bisschen soja also
ein bisschen auf asiatisch angelegt ist
aber das kann gut schmecken glaube ich
die andere seite reichen absolut bekommt
jetzt ein bisschen saure sahne hinzu
natürlich benutzt man da eigentlich so
flüssige sahne die auch sei es glaube
ich habe keinen plan
lacht ich würde nicht zu sehr aus
ich will eigentlich sagen der film ist
ja nur leute das kann ich so empfehlen
so nudeln mit sojasoße das kann wirklich
gut schmecken nicht zu viel aber ich
feiere das extrem wenn man dann noch ein
bisschen krieg über streit von meinem
gewürzen mir das vielleicht bisschen
viel gewesen und jetzt parieren war das
ganze jetzt richtig neugierig machen
alex jacob
woher kommt also meine haut gegangen ist
gleich fertig für umgerechnet 80 cent
oder so da bist ja mehr
jetzt kommt der nachtisch ist das
schlecht was ist passiert
und dafür habe ich mir jetzt hier dieses
zitronen los gekauft eine ahnung was das
genau ist eigentlich ganz okay wenn ich
noch nicht so überzeugt von und das hier
ist ja an sich ganz normale sahen und
das heißt sie kann man auch essen oder
will man hier die sahne rein den rest
der saane dann kommt das zitronen muss
und noch ein bisschen schokolade und
dann haben wir also ein richtig meisten
schoko zitronen pudding oder halt auch
nicht werden wir sehen
[Musik]
ich habe mir noch weiße schokolade die
knalle ich jetzt einfach dazu ich weiß
das ist natürlich auch ein bisschen
teurer als dieser euro oder das kommt
noch obendrauf
aber das habe ich so zu hause und ich
finde das ist in ordnung wenn man das
einmal mir leid ich weiß film jetzt
besser nicht ihre sonst gibt's hält kann
sie jetzt online stellt ich habe gehofft
ich habe gehofft dass wir ein bisschen
fest aber es ist irgendwie überflüssig
ich habe aber die hoffnung dass wenn ich
das jetzt in den strahlend dass es da
oder restauriert fehlt jetzt nur noch
ein getränk da kann ich jetzt einfach
leitungswasser rein so eine
brausetablette okay das wird sogar
heuschnupfen ja alles noch lecker okay
ich bin wenn ich mit hauptgang
nachweisen und getränke ich werde sehr
weh dass da auf den tisch kämen auf den
tisch einer das hier ist hauptgang und
wie gesagt alles unter einräumen und
deswegen macht
das kann man eigentlich mit zählen also
kam halt aus dem leitungswasser kann ich
kann es selber schon kommen ernst nehmen
und das ist der pudding
ich habe so gehofft dass das besser wird
aber kann man hier kolumne
danke aber ich probiere das hat es ja
ganz klar
wir starten wir mit dem haupt mit dem
hauptgang
so schlecht schmeckt es erst gar nicht
also da fehlt ganz viel dass das halt
gut schmeckt davon sieben von zehn
branchen vielleicht ist halt einfach ein
euro zu wenig eine maximal mit fünf euro
oder so stimmt wenn ihr darauf blieb man
doch nach oben aber erstmal muss ich
jetzt dafür jedoch schon nach dem
springen und das
wow
wo ist das eklig also das können wir
direkt das kann ich nicht weiter ist man
muss konstant 06 15
vielleicht ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen
also ich hab sie haben sowieso abends
ich versuche jetzt noch einige nummern
zu essen aber sag mir bitte nicht böse
macht mich nicht zu da und in den
kommentaren dass ich überhaupt nicht
warum kann ich habe mein bestes getan
aber man muss halt einfach sagen ein
euro ist so wenig du brauchst mindestens
fünf um dir was leckeres zu kochen
glaube ich wenn ihr sagt mach das mal
geben doch nach oben
das hat über inserate alex wie und wir
sehen uns morgen wieder 19 uhr jeden tag
gibt es ein video das was von mir haut
rein
[Musik]